all right we are here back Rick Santorum
can you how can you reassure evangelical
voters that Donald Trump would change
positions again on issues like abortion
he has kind of flipped left on that one
look I I will tell you that I campaigned
against Tom Trump for the primary and
you know he was all over the map and
here's what I believe I believe that he
is a Republican I believe that he is
surrounded himself with Republicans in
his campaign I believe he's a he's
appointed people like Christie like
pence who are these all work is only a
recent Republican know how to admit that
is how many terrible no you're even a
Democrat there will be wait Donald Trump
a while back will back back this up
personnel is policy it's who you
surround yourself with sure it's who's
gonna and Trump has been pretty clear
I mean he's surrounded himself his pics
on the court I mean he's also right but
he's all it's all I don't know he's
getting pain it has a bunch of Democrats
from Michael Cohen to Omarosa it's not
very very many so those are personal
said he's surrounding himself with some
of those are personal friends and you
know look but that's an interestin you
can attest to this that a campaign is a
microcosm of how you would govern and
this has been a disaster it's a disaster
it's a clown show every week they don't
know what they're doing is that only
respect with all due respect this clown
show beats 16 other folks you had a live
including me who had who had a lot in
many cases a lot more money and a lot
better staff and a lot better
organization nicely decide this was 16
now I disagree even when it got rid of
every three vanity camera this is where
eating I think this is the new normal
and I act I think the selection of
politics I think you're making an
organization of politics and the use of
social media is transforming politics
and what we better get we better get our
hands well Jeff Ross you try always
trying to make friends I'm trying to
bridge gap
thank you what I love about Jeff there's
no question he has momentum I think
civilization had a great run
Rob Reider tis your upcoming biopic LBJ
characterized him more or less favorably
than other recent portrayals well what's
the last one was that all the way right
I guess well I think what I tried to do
is humanize him I mean he was in the
Woody Harris yes Woody Harrelson who's
absolutely brilliant in it I mean
off-the-charts brilliant yeah it you
know he's a very shota so showed us the
the think of it said he showed us
dancing member on this phone but he's a
LBJ is a very complicated character very
complicated person he was almost
Shakespearean in Aaron in a way I mean
he was odds with himself he was very
tremendously insecure and at the same
time tremendously effective as a
legislator so you know many people have
said if it not been for the Vietnam War
he would have gone down as a great
president when you think about the
accomplishments he had with Medicare and
the Civil Rights Act and the Voting
Rights Act and Medicaid and and Head
Start I mean he did everyone is for
those programs no no I understand but
say it like it's a university except I
think people do like Medicare they do
even the Republican of the war to change
poverty a couple trillion dollars later
has been an ultimate failure and the
whole thing about poverty
yeah use me the war on poverty has been
a disaster you're kidding have you been
to any urban cities lately look at but
look at look at look at very senior
items of like urban America today versus
fifty years ago and you tell me that the
state of urban America today is better
than it was no no that's right it's a
disaster but Medicare was a big part of
the war on poverty a war on poverty is
an overarching name and they're going
wait a second to that before the war on
poverty and medicare something like
twenty eight percent of seniors lived in
poverty now it's under ten
that's called a success except that it's
going grow I get that you'll never be a
I'll never student it's going broke yeah
yeah providing health care open like
twenty forty ideas and I drank fighting
health care is one thing that way it
provided is is too right
and what about the what about the Civil
Rights Act and the Voting Rights Act a
very very public in an oven by the way
because Allah gave the Sunoco industry
that's true that ruin and it turned the
south into result scible people on the
left by the way twenty years after
sensible Democrats are for fixing it as
I recall President Obama wanted a grand
bargain and sewn in John Boehner who
stopped it on entitlement reform the
rednecks in y'all heritage now absolute
the tprop a half the wake used me John
Bainer
and Barack Obama wanted to have a grand
bargain a few years ago on this Obama's
the one who put entitlement reform on
the table for a little bit of tax
raising of the tab that he's proposed he
proposed noting that he put it on the
table said I'd do it but he proposed
nothing then why didn't I give schoener
want the deal look we need to have
entitlement reform we need to have a
bipartisan deal on that but the
president has to lead and he didn't you
know you never give the other guy credit
for anything I get credit when he leads
they didn't lead oh please I asked us
Jeff who would be your dream roast that
guy Thanks
let's go bring the food what I don't
understand is if you're both Republicans
what help me understand how one can go
for Trump and one couldn't what's the
what's the one issue
what do you grab on to where you that
pushes you to over to endure after being
I'm not the one leaving office for him
so he's she's a common I understand a
little different right so you feel
beholden to the point oh oh no Sarah Lee
at all what it is but I mean Rick has
been in the arena right you know it's
sitting senator in terms yeah that's a
little different than someone like you
or me or Tara who just talks alright no
that's for now
I didn't just talk though I worked in
Capitol Hill for many years and did many
things that affected people's lives no I
worked for an officeholder but it
affects people's lives I mean
officeholders don't do anything without
their staff so it's not like I haven't
do anything yeah yeah it is a little
different to hold the office no
absolutely view there is a certain
there's a lot of conflict I have friends
on Capitol Hill you know other
congressmen who are there they're
tormented over this decision because
they feel a certain obligation to you
know to the party into their
constituents who want to vote for this
guy but at some point you have to stand
up like Adam Kinzinger just did and say
you know I'm an American first and this
is unacceptable and Donald Trump doesn't
really represent what we do we would
never put up with this we are criticized
people are making excuses for Donald
Trump that they would never allow a
Democrat to get away with and I think
that's hypocritical okay let's get away
from politics for a wrestler
before our break Olivia our wants to
know will Brazil be able to pull off the
Rio Olympics without any major health or
security event security events maybe
health I don't think so I gotta say what
is [ __ ] I mean I remember reading about
Brazil only a few years ago like they
were the new right bigboy country on the
block and now I read that they pour the
sewage right into the water without
draining it you know you know the of the
50 cities of the most violent cities in
the world Brazil has 21 of them yeah
64 thousand murders a year geez how much
did they pay the Olympic Committee to
get to get the Olympics because they
they never should have been real never
should have been selected it was
ridiculous I mean it was only a year
after the selection that that Brazil
went into a major recession it's corrupt
their president is impeached for
goodness sakes and people were rioting
in the streets because of eminent domain
the Olympics come in they take people's
houses and they think they make all
these promises but the people there are
looking stuff but it used to be why we
got the countries that can't sustain it
used to be when you got the Olympics you
got your [ __ ] together right yeah you
know was like this is our moment the
world's gonna be looking at us well now
there sits in the water
you